hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Eve now this is the game
that you have been asking me to play for
so long ever since I played the witch's
house this game has been highly
requested and I'm finally getting to it
because I finally got it to work I think
but let's get into it
no time to waste now I do know in the
early afternoon under a grey sky even
her parents were on their way to an art
gallery did you remember everything Eve
oh do you have your handkerchief
you know the one you got for your
birthday keep it safe in your pocket
okay don't lose it why not mother father
mother father now this is an RPG horror
game and probably what you can probably
see right now
well we're here this is your first time
in the art gallery right EEB we're happy
to here to see an exhibit exhibition of
works by an artist named we're Tina and
they don't just have paintings but also
sculptures and all kinds of other
creations I don't doubt that you'll even
enjoy it should we get to the reception
desk oh yes let's get some pamphlets at
well as well so anyway my plane no not
yet hmm you want to go on ahead of
really EEB oh oh all right just make
sure you're quiet in the gallery okay
don't make a ruckus oh I'm certain that
the demons are gonna make a ruckus and
not me
don't cause other visitors in trouble
alright so now I'm playing now anyway
what I was saying before is that
obviously this game is an RPG horror it
doesn't have the best graphics but
really the point of the game is more
through the story than the graphics
itself and obviously it's very pixelated
on all that but once you look past that
I've learned to look past that in gaming
I mean obviously because I've come from
way way way way past in DOS games you
know some of the good excuse me did
something just flicker what happened
why'd the music stop what is that
enlightenment dark figure that's a cat
that's a lady melting I think those are
some hanging lights um a little
concerned as to why the music stopped
let me actually check downstairs first
wait was that me hang on I thought I saw
something here
lady in red no that's not me this is big
I creepy alright then
wasn't oh that's what happened everybody
died the end of story
wait what is that I hear something hello
oh oh that was the saving doodad okay
never mind then whoops okay
who's uh who's slapping around there why
is there a big portal to a underwater
adventure in the floor I don't know some
of these words probably cuz I'm just a
little kid who doesn't excuse me excuse
me cover your mouth if that was a sneeze
which I think it sounded like okay so
what's what what's the deal what's the
dealio am I supposed to look at all the
paintings there certainly are okay I
thought thought I thought the slippy
slaps weren't going on over there a
well-meaning booth welcome to the world
of guerre Tina we're truly thankful for
today we're current holding an for the
great artist Y skirt to do una thirteen
didn't I die oh okay I thought I heard a
motorcycle outside of one girl was going
on there um hi hello it doesn't look
like it's locked but it won't open
what did it look all right you're gonna
be a little jumpy are ya huh
looks like someone was banging on this
sounded like it - how strange
hello mr. eyeball worried
I'm worried about something all right hi
you dropped your Apple out of the
painting which makes total sense things
ain't seem to be urgent I heard that the
hell is going on here oh is that drippy
drippy blued come EEB come i'ii come
yaaaa
I'm not sure wait no old it change it
change its changed come down below Eve
I'll show you someplace secret Tom where
where do you want me to go and why me
I'm just a little girl I don't mean
anyone I'm just a little girl
I have a thyroid difference in T and my
voice is little deep in Santa like don't
my oh I see what's going on here uh-huh
oh wait a minute
blue footprints blue guy playing the
piano
ooh jump jump right in perfectly normal
perfectly normal
okay red pits of hell and blue pits of
hell
what does it all mean come come come
come baby there's a rose sitting in the
vase take the rose
yes obtained a red red rose and I got a
new counter up in the top left for the
red red rose I don't know if my face is
ever that lady's hair coming out of the
painting hi lady I got your key you okay
when the Roses did so too will you find
it well you don't know some of the words
why not cuz once again it's the little
kid
yeah it's not creepy that creepy oh the
letters turned red you and the rose or
didn't know the weight of your own life
you don't know this word okay what it
thief thief I don't know what you're
talking about
I didn't Oh looks like the pathways
disappeared I kinda like this the MU
fish you don't know this word baby say V
what is going on
use the blue key oh boy what is that
what is that this is a bug come here bug
what what you say what you say to me I'm
an ant
I love paintings my painting is really
cool I'd like to see it again but it's
kind of far away that's weird
beware of edges what does that mean
be butterflies spider some people have a
very significant fear spiders
that's the metamorphosis assists of a
butterfly oh okay you can't cross this
hole in the floor why not just jump your
little girl okay never mind then I'll go
elsewhere hey I think I want a refund
whoa
oh that's what they meant by WiiWare of
edges I have two roses left so the roses
are my love I goddamn it I'm such a
freak frakking idiot I should have done
that
beware of edges duh remove it okay now
go show this to the pan hey mr. an there
you go there you are oh that's my
painting it's just as cool as I remember
it stare no time for that we have to
keep moving everybody but what's that
thing find you nothing we must keep
going okay I did and I'm dead ie I
fumbled the keys didn't mean to do that
little anticlimactic
no thank you the thing there are
frequent save points use the blue key
dot text two creepy bastards don't touch
the blue key or the button the blue key
the edges of the walls
they'd hand-painting now go straight in
and then duck to mr. int it's my
painting just cool as I remembered so
now why what does that mean I don't know
okay just continue straight and continue
on say we good to go all right cool
what do you mean it's locked does that
little ant supposed to give me something
maybe I want to use its painting as a
bridge to get across the hole in the
floor does that make sense
ooh yeah that bit makes sense it tore
isn't that a bad thing
shouldn't I be okay never mind you know
what never mind apparently hi bunny
how you doing you're looking awfully
good you've been working out you look
fantastic man we haven't seen each other
in years we should catch up sometime
yeah but not now okay
you're gonna fall in the bin you're
gonna die aren't you fall in the pin die
clip on the bend I fell in the pin died
yeah I didn't see if on the pin die
something makes me want to not wish I
saw that I don't even know what that was
it was a red goo B GABA something I
don't know what though but make a good
progress for this if you like I'm moving
pretty quickly
besides Lou
hi what a hell are you
fish-shaped hold really a fifth hole
does this kitty cat wanna fish oh my
that is the most disturbing with the
least about a use out of it play hiding
on Oahu I didn't want to I didn't want
to play hide-and-seek don't press it
what it what's the punishment for
missing the wrong oh you saw a very
sinister painting but what does that
mean what does that mean painting of a
musical note oh hi did I find you found
me you get a prize Oh No
am i dad am i but what well yeah but my
grade get it off
look at a fish get a wooden fish can I
uh can I not have this giant red hand
print of death on me Oh might as well
get the others
oh jeez sorry for you naked I couldn't
see cuz it was a giant handprint in the
way maybe why do I keep looking at these
things I got it right with no punishment
now I lost a rose hey don't you I don't
want to be in here this is not good oh
goodness gravy gosh Oh bye Oh eyes are
you moving
oh-oh-oooh-oh-oh died why did it die I'm
so confused
can I have that I want that red red rose
I needed to replace my Wow what is it
what but Wow
I have five roses I guess my face is in
a different position now I fully
realized so you guys can see how many
roses I have
I got a fish key I got a fish key got
keya fish two fish key the put in here
insert the fish that was both adorable
and terrifying at the same time well
done I'm gonna save can screw that tail
is going on
you can see why you guys wanted me to
play this this is actually don't you be
bleeding at me you know what that
reminds me of you know another first
ship don't spit at me you rude bastard
you're in the first super mario world
under the super nintendo the boo ghosts
the small ones if you like looked at him
long enough they would make that face I
don't know if any of you know that or I
play that game ah come on donkey why is
it spinning
ah aesthetic dark Scooby does when
you've forgotten just when I forgotten
why beware of lips really really really
really Boop beware of lips huh really
really really
okay all right you know what all right
oh I'm ready for you baby ah I might as
well die I shaved Oh ate my brain be
dead
I'll I didn't want to lose that health
from the acid so I'm cheating stop
cheating
it's exploiting a perfectly legitimate
strategy oh no way oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're making
that goofy face it mean totally it's not
totally white what are you blind
looking closer to there's actually a
small number in the center nine
what does that mean why do I need to
know about the number nine wait what oh
my Wow oh just what I've forgotten about
the edges okay I was kind of distracted
by the people hanging by well they're
deep it's not good the liars room that
mean that everyone in here is a liar Oh
God now one of these puzzles again yeah
I'll be right back I gotta find out
what's going on over here the dangling
from are you sure these are just dolls I
know you said that it was a doll but I
mean doll on the ground all Clemson say
9 18 I'll write these down 9 was red 18
was that yellow green it is green it's
clues I know that in these RPG games a
lot of clue waste stuff wait a minute
there's a shadow here but I don't see no
body of bear what's going on oh I don't
know the purple one yet so I'll be back
in a moment
I'll be back right back don't go nowhere
just hang on I guess I got to figure out
the puzzle in here and then then it'll
be good stand in front of the statue go
west three steps south one step that's
the answer
what does that mean stand in front of
statue go for oh my god don't do this to
me
the one in white speaks the truth are
you lying
only truth bigger where's green are you
lying wait if it's the only truth bigger
where's green that means you're not
telling the truth anyway so and yellow
ones telling you lie too because then he
would he wouldn't be you wouldn't be
there can only be one right damn from
the stats you I agree with the one in
yellow you agree does that mean you
don't agree with the one in yellow
you're lyin and he's lyin he's a liar by
default because he can't be the right
guy
truth bigger can't me green ergo and the
one in white is probably lying to begin
with and the one you don't agree with
yellow it must be this one right stand
for the Statue four steps then one two
steps East for North to
I did it what happened
please well there will happened get a
for what happened oh they're all dead
they all killed each other they all
killed the DRO
oh my liar Oh God you didn't like that
did you crazy bastards alright I'll
solve this puzzle in the next one this
is actually really cool I really like
this bunny I'm actually sorry that I
didn't spend more time getting this to
work up before but I'm glad I am now
because this is really cool I'm having a
blast playing this one not only is it
creepy it's also fun
that's great horror game right there so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
ha ha